every August the best dota 2 teams
travel from around the world seeking to
raise the coveted Aegis at the most
prestigious competition in eSports the
international over it's short but fabled
history the International has managed to
produce more than a few of DotA's most
unforgettable stories
but before more heroes and legends are
added to the competitions lowered this
summer let's look back and relive the
most iconic moments in the
internationals history the fountain
hooks still hasn't even been used
there's a hill but all the way back to
the base raised up by the fountain
game-breaking brilliant hilarious
cheating no matter how you describe it
nabis fountain hooks from ti3 is still
one of the most unorthodox strategies to
ever be used at an international only 15
minutes into Game three of their upper
bracket match against tongfu Navi found
themselves with their backs against the
wall
sensing incoming defeat puppey and dendi
pulled out the ultimate cheese strategy
the fountain hook the product of a
unique interaction between Chen's test
of faith and pudges meat hook the
fountain hook created a long ride to
certain death for anyone unfortunate
enough to be caught on the end of it
from there things became more and more
ridiculous as Dendi landed hook after
hook that's a much better choice all I
got it after cook there we go the hole
got him up
in the end despite its absurdity the
chief strategy was crucial for securing
nabis comeback while the interaction
would later be patched out of the game
this iconic moment forever stands as a
testament to not only na vi's
inventiveness
but the near endless possibilities of
dota I cannot believe that they actually
did it the mega creep comeback
[Applause]
that game was out of control that's a
game that just makes you love dota 2 in
the sixth year history of the
International no team had ever
successfully overcome a mega creeps to
take the win
that is until August 10th 2016 when eg
Metis home an absolute slugfest of a
match as this is one of the best games
I've ever seen from minute one both
teams went blow-for-blow
in it over the ice life cycle and either
the chromosphere will secure the kill
[Applause]
everybody will be back for me another
five back with the boots of travel up
til they're going off the universe dad
but II home slowly ground eg down and
put forward eventually claiming all
right he's gonna be able to take that
Mahler x-range rank up next Bailey or
Ricky town ice flats coming in it's this
rain track that's gonna be making the
big just guilty PD with the impossible
challenge of overcoming Megas in front
of them eg didn't waver putting up and
come believable defense somehow climb
their way back into the match
somebody's still managed to get himself
away in the back light the space was for
you
get a run in subway universities
[Applause]
the LCDs is cool calm collected they're
holding those events here and potential
chicken
what's the game well past the hour mark
the mega Stretton in their every move eg
took the momentum of their valiant hold
and brought the fight to ehmm front door
bring it on
[Applause]
as the crowd blew the roof off Key Arena
PG cemented their legendary status with
one of the greatest dota 2 comebacks of
all time the deny from the International
2013 KY XY z-- deny is one of the most
infamous blunders of DotA's history and
is iconic for all the wrong reasons
fans of wit run-up then I want to deny
that they failed just I couldn't watch
the game for five minutes because I was
just like completely mind blown over the
fact that he had just an idle agus in
the lower bracket finals orange eSports
took on Navi for the chance to face
Alliance in the grand finals orange came
into the series hot and jumped out to a
strong lead in a deciding game three
against the favorites orange claim all
the out of t1 towers and they haven't
lost a single one yet man this is just
like full agent power for heading
through Navi Messi now be up Noah answer
to this orange was in a commanding
position and opted to take roshan to
ensure the win but that's when disaster
struck and no hands of whit runner did I
want to deny that they fail as Roshan
died KY XY missclicked
destroying the crucial aegis of the
immortal just before his team could pick
it up and there the pressure even though
all these players are trying not to
think about it when they're in the game
but when you're up and one game is what
makes the difference between going
through grand finals or not it's always
there without the aegis in hand orange
was unable to close out the game safely
ultimately creating an opening for Navi
puppy well he's got the black card he
got free they couldn't get it they
tarnish luster
na'vi capitalized on oranges misfortune
and charge back into the game overcoming
a 7,000 gold deficit knocking orange out
of the event while KY XY is still a
celebrated player this moment will
forever linger adding to the cruel
iconic legacy of this miss play is the
fact that to this day ages denies are
still called KY ex-wives the six million
dollar echoes run together DVD here
comes the ice
from the grand finals of ti5 the six
million dollar echo slam is not only one
of the nastiest two-man wombocombo
you'll ever witness it was the
tournament winning play for Evil
Geniuses up to the one in the grand
finals against CDC gaming evil geniuses
the hometown heroes appeared to be on
their way to victory in Game four then a
glimmer of hope presented itself for CD
EC a catch off to sumail creating an
opening to take roshan and potentially
reclaim the momentum but as quickly as
the window opened for C deck PPD and
universe slammed it shut even faster
unleashing their Ultimates onto their
unwary opponents to devastating effect
there is no shot they're all together
PPT he comes the ice floss or any
only ten minutes after this game
defining play eg would hoist the ages as
North America's first ever champions
[Music]
s4 is million dollar dream coils from
the epic grand finals of Ti 3s 4s
million dollar dream coils are quite
possibly the most clutch plays in dota 2
history TI 3's grand finals was the
culmination of one of the game's best
rivalries Alliance versus not be the El
Clasico of dota we go with the title on
the line in the deciding game 5 both
teams were digging a deep Alliance
started slow day giving Navi again the
relocate goes back out and strikes
pulling away with this game bono car
both are well
that's when the lion started to do what
they do best split push because this
they might not be able to stop it
TP back in here any bashes
Navid ripped up mid attempting to force
alliance to defend when it became clear
their strategy wasn't working na'vi
tried to build but s4 had something to
say about that
got a trophy people
with Nabi installed in their recalls
Alliance took down two lanes of rats
completely out maneuvering arrival
Kroenke he's dead Caracas down all over
alive the tapes are under a terrible the
hexes are public funding center go down
what's wrong
as the game was coming down to the wire
s for once again came up absolutely
mastered
but it's gone down it could be Japanese
understand Danny's back he's gonna try
to focus everybody but there's so much
stuff
a half HP Accord HP
Soraka for long sigh baby
while there is plenty of debate as to
which of the two moments is the true
million dollar coil there's no doubt
that both are spectacular
the plays catapulted s4 into the DOTA
pantheon and helped Alliance secure the
ages in one of the most epic finishes to
any international dramatic sensational
and undeniably clutch s4's million
dollar dream coils are the definition of
an iconic dota moment
sometimes one man can make all the
difference in the world
and during the International 2013 that
man was balled up who helped carry Team
Liquid to one of the most dramatic
upsets of all time when liquid met LGD
gaming China and the lower bracket of
ti3 everyone predicted that North
America would once again fall short
against the Chinese powerhouse if you
play a standard game against LG China
I'm not sure what oh they'll take it
from them however in a now legendary
game Galba on clockwork went to work
picking LGD apart across the map and
landing crucial hooks to give liquid a
chance to get you out it's got a bunch
our thankfully for North American fans
liquid did not waste the opportunity
produced by Balthus heroics closing out
the upset with a brilliant
and still standing strong second our
beam it's gonna come right now that also
catches three Sylar with the right
clicks if he gets up by it's like this
road is gonna get what my traffic wins
the man fight job bagging votes back get
back over there win the team fight with
l DS famous call resonating spur of the
building North America emerged the
victor
father
the mass remains iconic for not only
bald is ridiculously her own individual
performance there's no doubt about it he
was the MVP of the match but the
significance of the wind in the
landscape of any dota I need to play
what can you say about the play that
hasn't been said already from the
International 2012 the play is still to
this day donors most famous moments a
highlight you simply need to see to
believe
thanks warm up the river patience from
so waiting in the wind now he is about
to be caught oh they're asleep yes sir
he catches everyone
in a crucial Game two of their upper
bracket match against Invictus gaming
Navi was in firm control with eyes on
the tier two bottom lane Navi gathered
themselves and grouped forefoot news
exert their control over the map sensing
an opportunity to mount a comeback
IG didn't hesitate wrapping around
behind Navi under cover of smoke
IGS plan worked perfectly catching Navi
off guard and setting up what looked to
be an absolute devastating team played
the shorter path they warm up the river
patience from so waiting in the waist
now he's about to be caught
oh there's the sleep but sir he catches
everyone oh this could be a total
disaster
thank you everyone the black ball
like that
that's why I'm trying to survive
Schwantz gonna come down
puppy talked about the Nagas canner
however light of heaven popped his BKB
landing a massive four-man black hole on
the rooftop IG completely reversing the
trap at the same instant Dendi force
staffed himself out of a G's attacks
stealing ravage and returning it in kind
leading Navi to decimate IG and a clean
white Navi would go on to not only win
the game but the series as well
advancing them into the top three at ti2
while IG would earn their revenge in the
grand finals to claim the ages for
themselves it does little to tarnish
what is DotA's most iconic moment of all
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure that hit that
subscribe button
[Music]